[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle bastien le françois je suis
le premier pilote de dirigeable solaire
et j'aime bien me promener dans les bois
alors vous y emmène comme on est tous là
on va partir d'ici on va aller en forêt
de meudon mais par une après midi de
l'été 1884 alors mon temps sur le
plateau par la fontaine dur sin
redescendons après avoir traversé du
côté des étangs de meudon et tant qu'on
y est on va passer on va pousser jusqu'à
l'étang de chalais vous savez là où il
ya le hangar d'ailleurs en passant là
devant ces curieux il ya du bruit
je sais pas vous mais moi j'ai jamais
vraiment perçu une activité la dernière
et pourtant aujourd'hui on entend des
voix
attendons d'en voir un peu plus depuis
l'état lui là où il ya pas trop d'armes
on arrive à percevoir quelque chose une
énorme enveloppe fait bien ses 50 mètres
de long sous laquelle ils suspendent une
longue nacelle en bois avec d'un côté
comme un grand gouvernail et à l'autre
extrémité une hélice en bois à la
démesure du reste elle a bien l'air de
faire quatre fois la hauteur d'un homme
dans la nacelle deux hommes et autour
une petite équipe et s'affaire à des
préparatifs on dirait qu'ils ont presque
fini lâche eto'o lors d'un vote anti et
puis 10
le dirigeable s'élève lentement
une fois bien arriver au delà de la cime
des arbres on voit le lys se mettre en
rotation les dirigeables commencé à
avancer et s'éloigne vers le sud jusqu'à
être masqués par la cime des arbres
on voit pas ça tous les jours si vous
n'en croyez pas vos yeux vous rassure il
ya d'autres étaient moins juste
au-dessus l'observatoire de meudon était
le mieux placé pour prendre le seul
cliché de ce vol alors notre dirigeable
il partit vers le sud
mais l'équipe au sol et rester là mais
moi je m'attendais à ce qu'ils aillent
re vaquer à leurs occupations
maintenant il reste là il continue de
regarder le ciel dans la direction est
parti d'anjouan
c'est à dire un bon moment bon quart
d'heure plus tard petite agitation
encore et puis on entend un bruit une
sorte de bourdonnements sifflements
précède de peu l'émergence du dirigeable
de derrière la cime des arbres
on voit faire un grand virage
redescendre et revenir se poser là d'où
il avait décollé c'est le 9 août 1884
c'est la première fois qu'un aéronef
machines volantes construite de la main
de l'homme revient se poser à l'endroit
de son décollage
ce jour là l'homme a prouvé qu'il était
capable de maîtriser un vol alors pour
bien saisir la portée historique de
l'événement faut commencer par
comprendre que jusqu alors la direction
des vols a toujours été plus ou moins
subi le vent c'est un peu comme un tapis
roulant sur lequel on monte quand on
décolle et jusqu alors nouveau les camps
ballon libre c'est à dire qu'on avait
pas d'autre moyen que de se laisser
porter par le vent
plus exactement par les vents parce que
selon l'altitude on se trouve le tapis
roulant n'a pas forcément la même
vitesse ni la même direction
donc ça laisse tout un champ de
possibles mais ça oblige à composer avec
les vents du jour être dirigeable
précisément ces pouvoirs se diriger se
déplacer sur ces tapis roulant
donc ça nécessite un propulseur une
hélice et de quoi le fait de quoi le
faire tourner un moteur et de l'énergie
un carburant
alors en ce siècle de révolution
industrielle les moteurs j'ai pas mal de
développement de ce côté et dans les
décennies qui ont précédé le vol de
meudon plusieurs inventeurs +0 notons
tenter des solutions pour
propulsé leur aérostat à la force
musculaire d'abord si si et à la machine
à vapeur
mais cet été 1884 c'est bien un moteur
électrique alimenté par une pile qui a
rendu tout cela possible
là on est en 1884 à peu près quinze ans
plus tard il ya eu un autre
développement qui est apparu le moteur à
explosion bien connu qui lui fonctionne
avec un carburant particulièrement léger
donc qui permet des vols beaucoup plus
long que les 23 minutes du vol de menon
le transport aérien commercial remonte à
cette époque-là en allemagne d'abord et
puis dans les années 20 c'est carrément
la traversée de l'atlantique qui est
rendue possible par ces machines là en
un à deux jours de moins que ce qui se
faisait en bateau à la même époque
et ça on a oublié l'extraordinaire
popularité que saab mais ces moteurs à
explosion ils ont aussi donné naissance
finalement à l'aviation l'aviation puis
assez formidable développement sur toute
la première moitié du 19e et du 20e
siècle
de sorte que dans les années 50 il ya
plus besoin que d'une vingtaine d'heures
pour traverser l'atlantique
donc à partir de ce moment-là de cette
époque là le dirigeable n'a plus été le
meilleur moyen de transporter vite et
loin de grands volumes transportés vite
loin et beaucoup
une sorte de toujours plus finalement ça
a été le la ligne directrice des
développements industriels de cette
deuxième moitié d'un team siècle les
dirigeables était plutôt lent volumineux
et sensible au vent du coup ils sont
assez naturellement retrouvé au second
plan des développements techniques
je vous propose de revenir un petit peu
sur ce que je viens de dire quand vous
lumineux sensibles au vent volumineux
évidemment puisque c'est leur volume qui
par la poussée d'archimède leur permet
d'être en l'air du coup ils sont lents
vous avez tous marcher dans l'eau avec
de l'eau jusqu'aux la 2g jusque là c'est
galère alors résiste à notre avancement
un autre avancée un autre déplacement
l'air c'est pareil ça résiste moi mais
quand on est un dirigeable on est
tellement plus volumineux on a tellement
plus de surface que ça résiste et plus
on avance vite plus ça résiste donc on
se contente d'un registre raisonnable
mais aller lentement ça peut être un
atout aussi je dis pas ça que parce que
je vois le chrono défile
mais quand il s'agit de regarder par
exemple on voit plus de choses quand on
reste longtemps en ballon vous propose
l'expérience unique d'un balcon sur le
monde finalement à la fois dominant est
parfaitement intégré puisque le vent
vous porte dont vous devenez le vent
vous faites partie du paysage et vous
parcourez en même temps comment parcours
aliot est d'ailleurs pour un aérostat
aller lentement
rien de plus facile
il suffit de ne rien faire et on flotte
sensible au vent il ya du vent
oui parce que si on veut aller sur un
tapis roulant qui va vite il faut
pouvoir courir dessus
si on n'est pas capable de courir il
faut juste s'assurer qu'ils soient
suffisamment lent que le tapis roulant
il suffisamment lentement si vous voulez
que je vais coller vous pouvez enlever
il ya des petits bouts de bois au pied
du haut bas du ballon si vous enlevez 1
devrait re décoller
donc il faut s'assurer que le tapis
roulant il suffisamment lentement quand
on prépare un vol en aérostat on porte
une attention particulièrement attentive
particulièrement fine aux conditions de
vent à la pile de tapis roulant de ce
jour là et finalement ça a été un peu ça
la plus grande intelligence des hommes
de meudon dont je parlais tout à l'heure
ça a été non seulement effectivement
leur innovation technique la pile le
moteur est le jeune mais ça a été de les
utiliser dans des conditions adaptées
ça a été de savoir porter à l'atmosphère
l'attention nécessaire pour que leurs
expériences se passe bien et ça a été de
le faire à cette époque là où on
connaissait pas grand-chose à comment ça
se passe là haut dans l'atmosphère un
peu comme moi finalement quand j'ai
commencé le ballon je connaissais pas
encore grand chose aux sciences de
l'atmosphère
j'étais
j'étais élève ingénieur à l'époque et
j'avais la tête pleine d'idées
d'énergies renouvelables de l'industrie
plus propre mais je pense que j'avais
surtout déjà moi aussi la tête dans les
nuages est une succession d'opportunités
de passer du temps justement avec ces
machines là à commencer par le ballon
libre moi aussi j'ai obtenu mon brevet
de pilote de montgolfière peu avant le
diplôme d'ingénieur et très vite très
vite avec une équipe d'étudiants
on s'est mis dans la tête de vouloir
faire voler un dirigeable électrique
d'un nouveau genre
c'est à dire qu'on a remplacé la pile
électrique de menon par quelques mètres
carrés de panneaux solaires et si on à
dirigeables aussi go capable de porter
son pilote
c'était une première mondiale ça donnait
7 cette machine de 22 mètres de long
de kilowatts à peu près est presque
aussi lourd de panneaux solaires que
deux pilotes adaptés des panneaux
solaires sur un dirigeable sur un
aérostat d'ailleurs quels qu'ils soient
gonflés les autres ça pose un certain
nombre de questions techniques mais le
défi pour nous aussi tenez beaucoup dans
les conditions d'opération puisque non
seulement il faut faire attention au
vent mais en plus cela il faut faire
attention à la lumière mais finalement
faire attention plus finement à son
environnement c'est un petit peu la
tendance de ce début de xxième siècle
notamment dans l'industrie des
transports
ça oblige à concevoir les machines en
fonction plus ciblée de ce qu'on veut
leur faire faire je prendre un exemple
imaginer que je vous demande de
transporter 500 personnes à l'autre bout
du monde en moins d'une journée
on voit tout de suite un cigare blanc
dld nouveau tout le long des surfaces à
l'arrière si je vous demande d'aller
chercher un homme en danger dans la
montagne
alors que la tempête approche l'appareil
on voit un rotor un petit rotor à
l'arrière une cage à oiseaux au milieu
on a tous vu ces machines là de plus ou
moins loin
si vous demande par contre de rester
longtemps longtemps au-dessus d'un
endroit donné ou alors d'aller
livrez vous cherchez une charge
volumineuse ou lourde où les deux
au-dessus à un endroit où il ya ni
routes ni aéroport ni porc ni réseau
ferré eaux fluviales
là ça commence à demander réflexion bon
vous commencez à me connaître vous avez
une vague idée d'où je veux en venir
mais l'image est quand même moins nette
est en fait ça fait tellement réfléchir
partout dans le monde que sur cette
décennie actuelle
plusieurs gouvernements ont consacré des
financements à ce que des programmes
industriels développent des solutions
qui n'ont jamais encore été aussi sûrs
qu'elles le souhaitent aujourd'hui
revenons une petite aventure là vous
nous voyez en vol d'essai au dessus de
la plaine de bruit à cette époque les
hommes ont visé une traversée de la
manche on n'a pas traversé la manche
mais on a quand même fait avec notre
petits dirigeables photoélectrique une
petite dizaine de vols des scènes
jusqu'à une heure même plus d'une heure
de vol tous en circuit fermé nous aussi
et depuis cette cette expérience acquise
au cours de cette aventure des
précédentes et des suivantes
aujourd'hui j'ai investi dans un de ces
programmes industriels dont je parlais
tout à l'heure je vous parlais tout à
l'heure
juste avant de la possibilité qu'offre
les ballons les aérostats de voir le
monde tout à la fois de près d'auch
dessus et de l'intérieur
mais justement moi si j'ai passé deux
fils je choisi de passer mon temps sur
ces machines là c'est précisément pour
pour explorer cette vision du monde
cette vision n'est plus conquérant mais
accueilli cette vision de la qualité et
non plus de la quantité avant tout on
fait amplement connaissance avant de
s'inviter on s'essuie les pieds avant
d'entrer en aérostat
on prend le temps parce qu'on n'a pas
d'autre choix de bien comprendre où est
ce qu'on s'installe et on prend
conscience que cette humilité là peut
nous ouvrir un champ de possibles très
vaste et très prometteur je vous invite
à y repenser dans quatre cinq ans et
quelques vous devriez voir réapparaître
ces silhouettes placide oublié mais
familière merci
[Applaudissements]